[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video I'm
gonna be talking about the best thing
about Mobile Suit Gundam iron blooded
orphans in my opinion iron blooded
orphans is definitely my favorite anime
that I'm watching as it comes out during
the winter 2017 season and I'm really
enjoying it a lot and that's why I'm
excited to do this video if you're new
to the channel here at anime up or we do
a lot of anime news series and analysis
so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and if you'd like to
chat with us about anime on a daily
basis you can join our discord server
link in the description so what is the
best thing about iron blooded orphans in
my opinion other than the amazing Opie's
and also the fact that this anime
finally answers the question what would
happen if coming up from Gurren Lagann
and Valletta knew from code geass had a
baby seriously think about it coming out
newman adi confirmed but the best thing
about this anime for me is how maturely
it deals with important social and
economic issues and how it depicts a
future in which capitalism has run wild
big corporations are so powerful that
they have their own private armies and
certain segments of the population are
discriminated against and treated as
subhuman or human debris and considered
good for nothing but manual labor or
risking their lives in battle our main
characters are orphans who have no
traditional family or system of support
and they're consistently used and abused
they are forced to work and risk their
lives doing hard labor and they are
abused and beaten by their superiors
after they are abandoned by their
superiors and left to die at the hands
of Gjallarhorn they rebel and form their
own company and they begin to create a
unique family of their own
the anime explores very interesting and
complex issues such as the meaning of
family the idea of capitalism gone wild
the abuse of common workers child labor
and child soldiers in many ways this
anime takes me back to the Industrial
Revolution and the Marx
critique of capitalist societies and as
a student of politics and philosophy
these are very intriguing subjects for
me so yeah what really stands out to me
with this anime is that it's not just an
action mecha anime the action scenes are
great they're really entertaining
however there is a deeper core to this
anime a deeper social economical
background that is explored in a really
mature and unique way and if you haven't
seen it yet be warned from this point on
there will be some spoilers so if you
still need to finish the anime go do
that right now and then come right back
season one follows techadon the company
that the orphans have formed as they
struggle to make it on their own as a
company and face many many challenges
however even though they lose some
comrades along the way at the end of
season one we do see techadon become a
powerful force in the world of the anime
and while some anime would have ended
the journey right there iron blood and
orphans does not do that at the
beginning of season 2 we see the issue
of child soldiers rear its ugly head
again in an interesting way because
techadon which was made up of orphans or
child soldiers became so powerful and
successful other companies started using
and abusing more child soldiers and
following in techadons example I found
this very interesting because while we
know that the orphans attack Adan had
the best intentions they didn't have a
choice but to rebel and create their own
company their success actually hurt
other people because now more child
soldiers were being used because child
soldiers were proven to be so effective
with the example of techadon this is an
instance of the anime actually thinking
about the consequences the real-world
consequences of actions and this is
something that keeps coming up again and
again throughout the anime as techadon
becomes more powerful they also have
more responsibilities and more dangerous
rivals they become a target and they
have to deal with the consequences of
their actions both for themselves and
for others the anime handles these
issues maturely it is not merely a case
of the good guys defeating the bad guys
and then everything works out for
everyone the issues here are much more
complicated and to emphasize again how
the show handles socio-economic issues
in a really mature way I want to bring
up a
detail from episode 35 this detail might
seem small at first it might seem
insignificant but in my own personal
experience it is actually quite
significant in this episode Judah Leah
tells us that she established a school
for orphans and in this school both the
tuition and the lunch are free and lunch
is free because she doesn't want the
orphans to have to work in order to be
able to afford food and this free lunch
stuff is actually an important detail in
my own experience as a child I actually
lived through the civil wars in the
former Yugoslavia and my family and I
were refugees as a refugee I moved to a
new school where they had a yearly lunch
plan and basically you would pay a very
affordable yearly fee in order to get
lunch every day served to you along with
the rest of your classmates now I was
fortunate enough that my parents could
actually afford this yearly fee so I
would get lunch served along with my
classmates every day and then it would
be a social experience as well we would
talk about what lunch is being served
this day if we're being served the same
thing too often and all that kind of
elementary school preschool kind of
chatter and talk however because of the
difficult economic situation as a result
of the civil war there were always one
or two students in our classes who could
not afford even this small fee for lunch
I still remember feeling bad for these
students who could not afford the lunch
they would feel left out they would
probably go hungry and they would also
not be part of our social interactions
as we ate the lunch together so yeah
even though this was a long time ago I
still remember it
I still remember feeling that it was a
sad thing that this was happening so
this sort of attention to detail to that
free lunch it really spoke to me it
shows me that this is a mature show that
the creators of this show really thought
about these things if these orphans have
a free lunch that means that they don't
have to go out and work more for food be
abused more by their superiors and so on
just like in real war death is always
present in this anime civilians are
killed all the time as a result of the
battles that occur and even important
and beloved characters are killed off
throughout the show episodes 40 and 41
really drive this home and again huge
spoiler warning
but in these episodes nos a Almeida and
laughter are all killed off and while
these deaths were really frustrating
because these were all really cool and
likable characters it also shows that
this anime is serious it wants to show
us that when you're in war when battles
are happening sometimes people die and
sometimes these people are not side
characters sometimes they're people who
are important in your life so yes even
though they were tragic these deaths
show the maturity of this anime and now
if you'll excuse me I'm just going to
freak out about the fact that Naz a
Almeida and laughter died because NASA
had his own spaceship full of women
it was the harem a spaceship harem why
does this happen why does this keep
happening it's coming out all over again
why anyways anyways I'm fine I'm okay
and speaking of coming out I saw a lot
of parallels between iron blooded
orphans and Gurren Lagann which is my
favorite anime of all time so I'm going
to talk about that a bit right now
be warned that some Gurren Lagann
spoilers are coming up so if you haven't
seen Gurren Lagann why haven't you seen
it go watch it right now immediately and
then come right back
both Gurren Lagann and iron bladder
orphans begin in a place where the main
characters are essentially children who
are forced to do menial work and are
abused by their superiors but they take
their faith into their own hands and
form a powerful team Tiger and Don and
techadon respectively and this team then
faces off against much stronger
opponents and rivals and yet triumphs
against all odds on top of that
Miccosukee and Oregon have a similar
relationship to Simone and kameena but
whereas kameena needs to first teach
Simone to believe in the me who believes
in you Mika believes in orga 100% from
the get-go so much so that this makes
orga feel a great burden and great
responsibility because he blames himself
for all the suffering Mika puts himself
through for orga and the others there is
a really interesting and nuanced
friendship dynamic between Olga and Mika
and I really enjoy watching and develop
just like I enjoyed the dynamic between
Carmina and Simone
we'll say of course that iron blooded
orphans is not a perfect anime and it
does have some issues one of the issues
that I saw in the first season was that
Koo Dahlia seemed far too immature and
naive to me to be the leader of an
independence movement it just did not
seem to me like she was nearly mature
and strategic enough at that point to be
hailed as a hero of a sort of
independence movement or revolution I
also thought that in the second season
it was very naive for techadon to leave
the earth branch in the hands of rowdy
che and takaki Roddy Chi of course ends
up betraying them he is not part of
their inner circle and takaki who is
still a child has no sense of diplomacy
or leadership so he basically just
follows Roddy chair along blindly until
he is finally rescued by the rest of
techadon and he realizes that rod each
had betrayed them all and finally
towards the end of the second season I
found it very frustrating that both
McMurdo and NASA allowed that bastard
jazz Lee to work behind their backs and
keep stabbing him in the back over and
over again you would think that by this
time these guys would be capable enough
as leaders to see what's going on and to
deal with the threat so yeah those were
a few issues that I noticed with the
show that I personally was frustrated
with however those are minor in
comparison to all the great positives
that I've seen in this show
so in conclusion while I thought that
the action the music and other parts of
this anime were great the best thing
about iron blooded orphans in my opinion
was how maturely they deal with
important socio-economic issues how
realistically they portrayed the cruelty
of war and how they give us a really
nuanced and balanced view of human
nature so what did you think do you
agree with me what was your favorite
part about this anime let me know down
in the comments I would love to hear
from you as always thank you so much for
watching and be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell for more
videos like this one if you want to chat
about iron bladder orphans or any other
anime on a daily basis you can join our
discord server the link is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]